welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham azuz and today
I'm in another we were being quite
viewing these I'm joined by Sophie Allen
who is a business development director
at Venna tricks and Venna tricks are a
specialist recruitment agency that
places SDRs into SAS companies Sophie
thank you for joining me thank you for
having me so obviously we're just having
a bit of a chat before we started where
I always like to start on this show is
how did Sophie Allen enter the lovely
world of recruitment let's start there
so I was living in Manchester in the
summer of 2012 and having just finished
University there so I started working in
a burger bar in Manchester called almost
famous which is based in the Northern
Quarter okay nice and got to the point
after about three months of doing that
where I decided I wanted to do something
that was a bit more regular hours 9:00
to 5:00 Monday to Friday office-based
and so applied for a couple of things
online got called by loads of recruiters
and one of them was a guy called George
that used to work at a company called
Celsius okay and so he basically invited
me to an assessment day which was for a
sales job for Virgin Media I had no idea
what sales was you don't really know
what virgin media was the Hat definitely
didn't know what recruitment was yeah
pitched ups the assessment day must have
done something right because at the end
of the day virgin didn't choose me but
they found well the director of Celsius
at that really and sat me down at the
end of the day and said have you ever
thought about working in recruitment and
I said pretty much although obviously
not said all the wrong things about what
I was looking for in an opportunity was
I really really naive didn't have a clue
about the world of business went back in
the next day for a final stage interview
somehow convinced them to give me the
job and then started working there
pretty much the following week awesome
so what I'm always interested so I know
when I go into recruitment I didn't and
I didn't find myself one of these
assessment that is what what was did you
have to do anything a bit interested in
this assessment they like I think
I had and on one of the episodes
recently was if you were in a hot air
balloon like you need to sell yourself
to everyone as to why you got to stay on
out or something it was a similar thing
it was such a long time ago now I can't
remember the specifics but yeah it was
very much introduces people get like fun
as you were doing that sort of thing
yeah they did and I couldn't believe
that I was still there at the end of it
because like I said I was completely
clueless and I remember there was
another girl there who was also called
Sophie who was like amazing on the day
so everything she did I kept thinking in
my head right I'm just gonna copy what
she what so always interested in here
people's faults like how what was your
perception of recruitment at that point
like obviously as you said it was a bit
naive yeah obviously didn't didn't
obviously know recruitment was an option
but like what was your perception at
that point and I don't think I had one -
because I didn't have a clue what it was
a guy that I was living with at the time
worked in recruitment but I didn't
really understand what his job was yeah
and then after I got the offer of the
final say Geneva Celsius I went home and
googled what is recruitment what the
recruiters do I've actually have some
answers to questions and just a sort of
frame art then so John so you ended up
obviously joining Celsius yeah and then
you worked there for how long and about
three and a half years okay cool so real
solid first in in recruitment right yes
yes so first job so
and what did Celsius do so they placed
graduates into sales jobs within the
tech sector okay and when I joined they
were based only in Manchester and then I
moved to London with the company to help
them open their office in London cool
so always love talking to people about
their first year in recruitment yeah
early days it's typically the hardest
it'll be really hard for me so what what
did you find yourself doing and I was
sort of first year or so was it was you
just sourcing candidates or did you get
starting to be decide what yeah so when
I first joined my sole objective was to
invite graduates to the assessment days
that we were running so we ran an
assessment day I think it was every
Wednesday and oh sorry we've done
there's a week actually one in
Manchester and then one later on in the
south and we were given KPIs on a
day-to-day basis based around confirming
a number of candidates for the
assessment dates okay so I was
understanding what the different jobs we
were recruiting for were and then trying
to invite candidates essentially to come
to the day and then so then how did it
how did it typically work then so like
see he was telling graduates to go to an
assessment day there was then so then
would the people with the employers be
there or was it was you guys then
obviously get people that you for
actually these people are great and then
you'd speak to them about different
companies yeah that's how it would work
sometimes employees with that but not
very often
okay so it's basically for you guys to
go right so let's get say 50 people in
the room exactly and then work out yeah
he's definitely up for this he's not
he'll be great who wouldn't be
and then what and then you would then
speak to clients about particular people
so in the first year I wouldn't speak to
any of the clients I just sometimes get
the opportunity to like take feedback
off the client about a candidate or
something like that and but it was
predominantly inviting people to the
assessment day and then once they've
been successful prepping them for
different interviews yeah okay how how
did you get paid then like so I guess it
would still be the same it would just be
once at candidates place yeah exactly
okay so you didn't wasn't incentive wise
to get people to the assessments than
that no contrary to what a lot of people
think about assessment days know that we
weren't incentivized like that oh it's
really interesting I think what was
because I've had so I've been running
obviously I had the experience recently
running an event for the podcast and
been involved in this sort of similar
scenario in my previous job and like
what was a typical dropout rate and
stuff of that was it quite high well
with our assessment days now I'd say
it's a lot lower
yeah and back then it was probably a lot
higher because we spend a lot of time
convincing candidates that they wanted
to work in sales yeah and whereas now I
think it's a much more
profession career choice exactly yeah
an industry that people actually want to
get into once they leave University yeah
so back then I'd say it was probably a
lot higher remember I'm one of the first
assessment days I'd invited candidates
to I had seven drop outs in a row on the
morning so so the first year then really
focus on candidates like how was that
experience be that was it was it
difficult you find it hard or what would
the challenges yeah I found it really
hard and but I also got the buzz for it
and started to love it pretty much
straightaway really and the way that
that company was run was quite I don't
like the phrase boiler room but it was
more of a bhoot boiler room style sales
environment so it's really fast-paced
yeah lots of outbound activity lots of
managers listening in on your calls
while you're having them and then
deconstructing them once they've
happened if they didn't go to plan
and so as tough as it was I think it was
a really great way to learn because you
were fully in at the deep end
sure and yeah I think that's really
helped me in my career really definitely
ok so let's talk a bit about obviously
leading up to you leaving to join
voluntary senso year-to-year free what
went on there than sitting because I
know obviously now your role is very
much client focused so like when did
this or that when did that transition
happen so in the first few months of
working at Celsius I met Elaine who is
the founder of Bennett Rick's yeah and
she was really impressive and we got on
pretty much straightaway sure and she
was in the in a transitional period
where she was moving to London to open
that office for then yeah and then they
basically asked me if I wanted the
opportunity to move to London with her
and help set up the office okay and so I
did that and then within about a year
and a half my role changed from
generating candidates to generating
clients and did you want that did he was
have important I actually really loved
the candidate side really good job yeah
a lot of people I think really want to
get out of that and do Bedi quite
quickly but I've really loved it and at
the time I think we needed more people
reaching out to clients in London sure
and I remember Elaine just kind of sat
me down and was like right we've got a
new and business
that manager and I said okay who is it
and she was like it's you okay so and
then so that was so that was what a
year-and-a-half in or she moved to
London year and a half and yeah no I
moved to London I think about three to
four months in all three to four months
yeah and then my role change how was
that a few person then so when she knew
Manchester living up there yeah and then
you just put all your eggs into like
moving to London recruitment career
lights proper went for it
yeah okay did you hide where did you
grow up um well I was born in Liverpool
grew up in Papua New Guinea in West
Africa
really yeah okay then moved to Swansea
in South Wales then went to Manchester
unity and then okay now my parents live
in Southport which is just outside of
Liverpool yeah I haven't got any friends
there because I didn't grow up there all
my family's northern say they're all
based okay so yes al I just interesting
because I've done that myself and I
think I don't know I think it can be
quite busy right I left I hadn't left my
friendship network and like stuff like
that so like that can be quite difficult
corner so you just went all in three
four months in as you said went into
equipment didn't even know that was an
option
I was working at a burger bar previously
so it's like you just went absolutely
love that yeah and then moved to London
pretty much all of my friends were
living in Australia after University
really well hadn't quite moved to London
yet yeah it's quite daunting yeah and I
think London can feel really lonely when
you felt live here and you don't know
anybody in it's such a big city
yeah the way the weirdest thing for me
is like just I've mentioned a couple
times but like you're surrounded by so
many people yeah you can feel really
lonely like you commute to work and you
that you just see so many people but you
could not speak someone all day in life
it can be hard Connor
okay so moosa' London so you pretty much
saved safety said then you pretty much
had to build up the the London part of
the business from scratch so we had
clients that were had offices in London
they're all worked with in the north and
yeah we pretty much had to build out so
yeah so yeah what was so you become the
new business of element manager that
what was the strategy his life and well
back then we didn't there weren't as
many cool SAS / technologies in central
London so we spend a lot of time booking
meetings with companies in the Home
Counties and travelling to those
meetings to pitch our services and then
convincing graduates that wanted to live
in London to go and work in places like
reading because they really this is that
we had jobs so but I think the strategy
then was just it wasn't as nice as
Bennett Rex
yes the strategy then was pretty much
any company that's hiring for junior
sales people you need to cold call the
decision-maker or try and get past the
gatekeeper obviously there weren't as
many sales tools sent as there are now
to get through mobile numbers and book
meetings and go and pitch the services
and convince them to give us a go
basically and you pretty much didn't I
have you been denied a sentence pretty
much yeah pretty much
so let's just let's just talk a bit
about breaking that down a bit in terms
of before you left overnight rates
because I think as I send you before a
lot of the topics that quite common
topic is business velopment yeah so like
I mean you hadn't I mean that you just
find yourself doing that role so I'm
sure you're like well okay well I'm
gonna have to crack on and just do this
so cold cooling trying to build
relationships getting opportunity
services like how challenging was that
um I think it was really challenging but
again I think that that shapes you into
the salesperson that you become in the
future because you're on the frontline
of the business and you're handling
every single possible objection you
could ever handle mmm you're having to
really kind of motivate yourself and use
a lot of self-belief and resilience so
even though it's tough I'm really glad I
went through that because it's made me
the salesperson how did you run with
that and so you mentioned their
resilience become more comfortable
rejection and I remember my yeah I mean
when I when I saw I started on the
candidate side and then when my boss
said ah why he should more and you start
sort of trying to build up your own
destiny our clients live absolutely [ __ ]
my pants like what I was trying to do be
the very difficult so how did you like
did how did you start carving that
did it happen quite naturally did you
learn from Elaine or like what did you
start doing that really enabled you to
get better at taking on that rejection
and so massively learnt from Elaine she
was really inspirational at the
beginning of my career she still is but
in learning how to do everything to do
with and it was it was quite hardcore so
if we if I cold called somebody and they
told me to get lost or hung up on me
Elaine would be like right phone them
back be like would you say something
along the lines of like so I understand
that you just hung up on me I can't
remember exactly but just try and get
them to I think a lot of the techniques
that we use back then were based around
empathy so sure because our client base
are typically salespeople because
they're leaders of sales to you know
junior sales people and a lot of it
would be based around if I was one of
your graduate sales people and somebody
had just hung up the phone on me what
would you tell me to do Wow so we did a
lot of that well yeah and then you get
to a point where you you've you've been
told to go away you've been hung up on
so many times that it doesn't affect you
as much and I think a big thing for me
is not worrying about the outcome of a
conversation because if you go on to a
call and you know feeling worried about
the person picking up the phone or what
they're gonna say once they find out
it's a recruiter that just ruins the
call from the very beginning I think
that's really interesting in isn't it
like sort of not having an outcome
attached to like what you want yeah
exactly you know I mean again yeah
you're right you get in your head
because you you're wanting to know where
you're wanting to feel like right how
how can this call go as best as it can
or how can I be successful but you're
better off not having an outcome
attached aren't you exactly yeah it's
like what for you what what do you from
your perspective you could talk about
now as well but what what in your in
your sort of your perspective like what
makes a successful business development
cool do you not I mean yeah so I think
first of all getting through to a
decision maker yeah because
and it might be different for different
types of recruitment but for us it's
very driven around having the
conversation with the right person from
the get-go sure so I think that's really
important I think a really confident
opening where you sound like really
energetic and somebody said to me once
that they really like dealing with
salespeople that sound like they love
their job so sounding very long way than
that yeah especially when you're
interrupting people's day exam like if
you've got a bit of energy about you
enthusiasm
yeah don't underestimate how important
yeah I think not waffling getting to the
point directly I think you can build
credibility by asking really good
questions that aren't just are you
recruiting thanks more around their
business and then not being scared to
close it full commitment at the end so
making sure that as in that so that
could be anything from let's booklet
alert you've told me this I think it's
fair to say that I'm someone that could
probably help you let's book in a time
to chat or like actually yeah yeah well
for us if they've got a requirement it's
always based around a face-to-face
meeting so okay at the end and making
sure that you agree a time and a date
that they can meet you nice I like that
okay cool and I think for me what I had
to get better at and I'm sure you've got
this proper now down now but sort of
early days it can be quite difficult but
it's definitely worth just having like a
bit of a solid spiel that you say she's
a solid personal pitch there if someone
answers it's like fact this is what I'm
hitting them with yeah yeah and is that
from your experience like I'm sure
you've got that really nailed down now
is it typically like look this is this
is a cold call we haven't spoken before
but typical are aware of these types of
business help than this how other now
light is it typically you just want to
say these this is a problem that I solve
is this sort of interest to you or do
you have this problem sort of thing
exactly yeah again because what we do is
so nice it's typically based around
placing STRs into SAS businesses and and
now because we've got so many clients in
London we can reference companies that
are similar to the company that were
mostly houses yeah and and also because
the SAS industry is quite connected we
can normally reference people that the
that we're calling is connected to on
LinkedIn or nose okay so quick quick one
then so knowing what you know now
mm-hmm what what would you say to Sophie
the new video manager we know now what
would be some of the things you
communicate to that person or people
early on numb what you know now what
would you say I think probably so
specifically around BD to just know that
not every call has to go well I think I
used to get really like upset or
stressed out ethical if I knew a company
was recruiting but then the call didn't
go well and I couldn't get them to meet
me because they were like it failed yeah
and I think a big thing is understanding
that not every call is gonna go well and
not every company is gonna want to work
with you but that doesn't mean that
you're not good at what you do it's just
the way that it is sometimes yeah and I
think people especially and clients
really appreciate resilience in a
salesperson or recruiter sorry not
resilience persistence so remembering
that just because they've said no the
first time doesn't mean that that's it
that's it yeah yeah I had a episode
recently here's a business owner and he
sort of told his trainees that when you
get the first know like that that's
actually when the fun starts or light as
in instead of just all that just
thinking about like you're talking about
they're always one in every call to go
perfectly if you get that first no he
sort of said to his guys that well
normally it takes about five nodes to
get a yes a like that first no he's just
okay now on to the next no and actually
seek noise yeah you know I mean I think
it's just a slightly from way of looking
at know is which massively helps that's
interesting so how so and just wrap up
your first first part in recruitment
career then so like so how did you do
balloons wise and stuff like the first
second or going into your third year
like how did that all go then so off the
top of my head I can't remember the
exact figures which is probably really
man I hold you against it but I think
yeah I think I did pretty well I think
I've done around 250 K by my second
third year I'm [ __ ] bad
that's great do you know that that's
good
okay so let's just talk about that for a
sec yeah so just two things before we
talk about Venna tricks and the journey
there firstly like so from so you said
there said was that your third year do
you say yeah okay cool so I'm assuming
before did you break the two hundred
came up before the in the second year or
not I actually can't remember school I
know that's really bad no that's okay so
so the reason why March about this is
something like I get quite a lot is he
shown I build 150k 180 K under the 200 K
mark basically I'd love his talk to
people about how they broke that times
okay mark because it can be quiet
a lot of people may seem one it's not
reachable to I build 180 K the last
three years where the [ __ ] when I get
an extra 20 K from so like what what was
your journey with that like how yeah how
was your experience in breaking that so
I think for me I've always been very
target driven so once I set my mind on
doing something I make sure I do it and
when we used to get given targets that
Celsius I remember I'd always have my
target and then I'd have the target that
I wanted to do okay and I would always
have like a like bit of paper on my desk
the ultimate figure at the top of it
beginning of each month and then each
time I made a placement I would knock
that money off knock it off until I got
down to zero you could always say that
they like having real short-term visible
yeah you always gave yourself Locker and
you do that the beginning the ELMO human
like yearly target and then you'd break
that down yeah okay how did that help me
then just because I think it reminds you
every day of what you're I think a big
thing in recruitment sometimes is you
can forget why you're doing what you're
doing yeah and when it when it gets
tough you can get kind of caught up in
it and you can't really see the
direction forward so I think having that
target next to you or somewhere where
you can see it on a day-to-day basis
remind you that that's what you're
working towards yeah and then every time
you do play somebody and hit their bit
of it off it's like a little wind yeah
I like that because I think yeah I mean
you hear that so much don't you like
breaking it down into because if you say
right my tum to give myself a target of
300k and they might send [ __ ] how am
I going to do that but when you realize
it's yes however much that is on a
monthly basis and you're breaking it
down each month that's really useful
so did you would you like review that on
a monthly basis yeah really yeah
definitely and did you just just out of
interest as you said in recruitment you
can quite quickly forget you can find
yourself forget them why you're doing
that
what did you attack obviously yeah you
got your mantra target but did you
attach anything to that like I don't
know if I hit that that means I can get
this or other neither did you what was
some of your wires around that I think
at the beginning of my career I just
really liked being known as somebody
that always hit their targets and always
did work and we used to do because the
company was split over two locations we
used to do and quarterly meetups where
we'd all present our figures okay and I
think that used to really motivate me
yeah quite competitive and but I
wouldn't want to be stood up there
having not hit my target and that
company employed lots of other really
good recruiters yeah so I did want to be
a form of the part no exactly I always
be top of the pack and then I also used
to have like mini monetary things that I
was working towards like in my first
year I really wanted to buy a prior to
him bag so when I got my first big
Commission check I went and bought that
and then I little things like why would
you say you're motivated by money
yeah really lately okay that's
interesting
would you no no it's just interesting
more on my own sort of journey with that
I think the reason why am i motivated by
any money yes but I think if you said to
me right he's him your target 100k this
year like for me to be really motivated
by 100k hitting hundred K and I would
need to understand personally what
that's going to mean for me besides
really works out for myself so my I have
a target first in business 200k right
and I made a decision not too long ago
to invest in the coach and it's been
great and one
things that we realized quite early on
is I'm just not something that's money
motivated so for me what I had to really
break down was right so if I hear if I
make hundred K in my first year that
means what does actually mean well that
means that I'm going to be able to and
really contribute to getting a place for
my girlfriend so we have our in place
and that means that I'm gonna be able to
take my parents away or whatever so I
need to like for me I need to know what
the [ __ ] hundred K means because I could
just look it on a piece of paper and it
wouldn't mean anything to me yeah I know
so then if you've ever had this but when
I got the biggest paycheck I'd ever had
improvement
I remember getting like I was so excited
by it and then the money hit my account
and I remember looking at like I just
didn't feel anything but if you ever had
that but I I don't know I was just a
really interesting moment for me where I
was like really motivated by money at
that point and when I actually got that
the money I was like I just didn't feel
any different mm-hmm other night it was
just an interesting insight for me yeah
I know what you mean I think it's more
than milestones that earning good money
can help you achieve in your life as
somebody who's in their mid to late
twenties living in London which is
obviously really expensive and so I
think that's that's why we're money
money has really motivated me and I'm
working on that's what I mean that's
like working out what those things are
yeah exactly and that definitely helps
when you've been told to do one like 50
times a day you know I mean remembering
that okay well actually if I keep one
one there could be one more no away from
getting a yes which means that yeah so
biggest learnings then in Celsius and
your sort of time there would you say
those were and I think that in order to
get the results you have to put in the
activity okay which going back to what I
said earlier about it being a very KPI
driven environment I think that in
recruitment obviously a big part of it
is your skill and your attitude but then
I also think sometimes there is an
element of luck yeah and you've got to
give yourselves as many chances as
possible together
basis and agree you may run like I think
exactly so I think that yeah just
high-volume about band activity gets
results and I think even now if we're
you know facing a week where we think
okay maybe our client base looks like it
could be drying up a little bit and we
might need to find another company to
invite to the assessment center we just
always take it completely back to basics
and think right these the companies we
need to call these the number of
decision-makers we need to speak to book
this many meetings to get this many
clients on board yeah I like that cool
so Ellen went off to start Vanna tricks
Yeah right and then you just to set the
scene so and then you joined Vanna
tricks a couple of months in yeah I'm
starting yeah exactly
okay and then you've been here now for
four in a bit cool and Venna tricks now
so it's a bit more niche that what you
do yes
so when we so when venit Eric started
and Elaine and I were really conscious
that we didn't want to create another
version of the company that we'd work
for once do a bit different I think
everyone starts a business had the dream
if we want to do something that's
different and doesn't feel like just
another recruitment company because
obviously is a saturated industry and
and I think that we were quite fortunate
in the sense that when we did start
Venna tricks was around the time when
all of the West Coast American software
companies started opening their doors in
London and lots of SAS businesses were
emerging that had VC funding it's a real
growth what you doing exactly so when we
first when we first started company I
remember my first day and doing BD I
booked a meeting with a guy called Mark
Wright and he won't mind me telling the
story he worked for a company called
impact radius okay and went to the
meeting and we obviously had no clients
not really any candidates managed to
convince him to agree to work with us
that are really really discounted fee
yeah and then he was basically looking
for three people and and then we got
loads of applications for the roles
and so then Elaine and I broke it down
and thought right wieder all of the
candidates want to work for this type of
company specifically and then we
realized it was because it was a SAS
company that had funding that had a
really cool office lots of growth
opportunities could pay a high basic
salary so then we basically decided to
form
Venna tricks on that on that yeah that's
interesting yeah so because I've had a
couple of questions recently on sort of
how people have sort of identified their
niche that's quite interesting how that
happens so yeah
instead of deciding that this is going
to be this is what we're gonna focus on
this is gonna be honest you've actually
took the context of okay Wow so one is
crying it's clearly there's something
that people are interested in here yeah
let's just focus on that yeah so that
sort of focus since then has been cstrs
is that like entry level sales positions
within such companies exactly yeah
and it's all grads majority of grads but
we do place people with experience from
time to time really but it's very junior
experience like they might have done a
year in recruitment for example or
different type of sales so since then
and so since then and that's what you've
been focusing on and your role has
always been clan development yes yeah
yeah okay cool so how did you find
transitioning then from cuz eventuates
I'm assuming at that point was a proper
startup yeah how's that view I think
that was like one other employee review
Elaine one other person start from
scratch no candidates clients yeah
exactly that like I think it was really
exciting to be honest really yeah I've
always had a lot of belief in Elaine and
me as a team and I've kind of always
known that whatever we put our minds to
we will be able to do it eventually even
though there will be hiccups away so it
just felt really exciting and and it was
quite it was quite refreshing to
actually start from scratch and kind of
think right we've got a blank canvas we
can make this whatever we want it to be
and again because we decided that what
we wanted to do was going to be quite
nice ship made the actual process of
doing business development
I was gonna say that yeah quite focused
because we were focused only looking at
a specific type of company so let's just
talk a bit about just break down a bit
about the sort of strategy and how they
execute so that happened quite
organically the experience you just said
so then after that when you like hang
them Annette this is a huge opportunity
like what what was the client
acquisition strategy of interest and so
as much as it was focused around
software companies it was very much just
phone everyone was it was it just
Blunden obviously london-based
and yeah just just London baby how did
you get at like how did you know whose
lies in did you just go on LinkedIn like
look I don't I'm sure you just did some
clever searches but we did lots of like
and fast growth company lists and like
the Deloitte fast 50 and large issues
all the resources out there exactly yeah
and then just try to get people's mobile
numbers really lusha we lash I guess I
heard about so Annette it's yeah it's
really good I get really mixed reviews
about it but I found it such a great
tool for BD so anyway it's meant being
mentioned a couple of times on the
podcast now but it's a lush are quite I
never used it but Luxur quite simply as
a tool that can enable you to get
people's numbers and you like it's like
a credit for yeah is that how it works
and so you buy credits on a monthly
basis it's really not expensive at all
and then every time you request a mobile
number it takes a credit off you and
it's from it's a lot I could be on the
sofa and could you be connected but
sometimes you will phone people and
they're like oh my god this is the tenth
time someone showed me today it's not
that number how accurate is it I would
say probably seven out of ten really
rational side is it yeah I was mental
but I was speaking somebody about this
the other day I don't know if that's
because the people that we're calling
because they're salespeople and more
likely to have their data online whereas
if you're targeting people just a bit
more who are already a bit more
reluctant yeah okay so so yeah so that's
really interesting so
mapped up the market essentially
identified who are other companies like
do you say radius it's good impact
radius I'm sorry who what other
businesses are like there there's and
then you just started just smashing out
the phone basically exactly yeah and
I'll pitch very much then with give us a
chance really
yeah we won't let you how did you find
that because it's really interesting
that because I think I sit down with
business owners and people like you and
I think it's actually surprising how
many people willing to help at the early
stage actually like a fan of quite a lot
they're people like well actually so if
you know what I'm happy to back here
looking out me and it's interesting like
how did you find that like what people
wanted to give you a chance and yeah
they were I think again because the
people that were selling to are sales
people they've nine times out of ten
they've been in the position that you
are with that we renowned that we were
in back then so that they appreciate the
kind of tenacity and the desire to do a
good job for a client and they're
inclined to give you a chance and help
you mmm so how was that first year than
alright so it was actually really
interesting because we managed to win a
big contract with a company in New York
really even though we'd never recruited
in the u.s. before and we had a company
that took on I think it was twelve
people from us in London and and then
they said that they needed the same
project delivering in New York and then
in Boston and we managed to we were up
against another one of our competitors
but we managed to win it so that was
pretty crazy because then before we knew
it we were on a plane to New York I
think that forty graduates returned so I
think I think that's one of the really
cool and great things around joining the
smaller great and businesses
opportunities like that yeah
because sure like that can just happen
my yeah and it's like yeah you have the
opportunity to be agile and black you
know what yeah we are actually know what
would do that exact I sell to do that
yeah okay so for you so the whole of the
whole time it's been your job to clients
blood relations etc right yeah so out of
interest and who's come up quite a few
times now
let's just focus on the biz development
piece like how what's your mindset
towards like if you win a new client
relationship we find terms is your
mindset right okay and perfect on to the
next one or is it right the fun starts
here how can we maximize this climb on a
ship so when we get the term signed we
don't invoice any money until the
candidates actually started so the kind
of journey doesn't end there with the
client yeah but because the companies
that we recruit for are growing really
quickly we always want to make sure that
they're not just going to take one
person from us that they're going to use
us as they continue to grow and so yeah
we try and do as much as we can to
maximize every account and make every
client feel really special and really
enjoy working with us and if you like
the reason why marcin's because I think
that's where again coming back to the
question of Billings and maximizing it's
kamek quite a few times where typically
recruiters can be prone to like right
perfect one that client yeah they just
get a new client new quite a new client
whereas the advice has come up quite a
lot where actually if you've got a bank
or 20 30 clients are you getting as much
out of those as possible like yeah so
that X client is paying you last year
paid as X how can we get that into 50
grand rather than 20 grand you go back
yeah so I think and for us because like
I said the company's growing quickly
normally they're taking on a lot more
than just one person and and because
they're because we run an assessment day
every Wednesday and our clients quite
often will come to the assessment day we
get lots of touch points with them face
to face
yeah which really helps and then in
terms of maximizing each account that's
something that we're looking at doing
this year in establishing our senior
division a bit more and so that we can
work on other vacancies that aren't just
STR yes a lot how you can expand the
accounts basically rather than what and
then your your mindset towards clients
now like had a chaplain and in the past
that was really interested in he was
someone who was really good at business
development and his sort of his sort of
advice was like typically a lot of
recruiters may
sort of you haven't gotten into like how
you structure a day which we'll go into
because this really common question but
I think what was really interesting what
he said was typically let's say that in
your Monday to Friday your week you've
decided that on Tuesday 10:00 to 12:00
and Thursday attend to our juggling
business development right and that your
mindset going into those sessions is
random business development now yeah
whereas for him the mindset shift that
he's had is quite quite subtle but so
it's just had a huge impact is for him
you're always doing new business you're
always obviously you're in and just a
fully business development Robert is
that very much a months at this you're
always doing it's always in the business
everything you're doing it right noob
isn't like business development yeah
absolutely
how do you start your days now like
pretty rigid or like how do you
typically strategy today so I would love
to say that it's really rigid but it's
not try and do yeah it kind of all
depends what's going on that week
because we do assessment days and lots
of events and also we run sales training
the weeks are quite busy and because
what we do is so fast-paced in the sense
that we're placing people that typically
don't have jobs into entry-level jobs so
the sales cycles are quite short the
environment is quite reactive because
there's every day there's interview
feedback to take job offers to make
conversations it's quite hard to live in
love right hey 10 to 12 I'm doing this
yeah I'll always do I've always got a
list of companies that I'm chasing and
when I get in in the morning the first
thing that I'll do is dial up to all of
those people to try and have as many
conversations as I can and then I do do
a lot of stuff on LinkedIn as well
really yeah just a quick one because I
was write it down when I was preparing
for this like how have you found
recruiting for grads so I was in the
session last week actually hmm and we
did when doing the sort of part the
exercise that I do with them thinking
about their clients of candidates and
one of the challenges that they found
their clients had that we were mapping
out was this snowflake generation yeah
yeah what does have interest is curious
like what's obviously low with both
young people like you enter you need
like one how are you fine
the grads or like I don't know how do
you find typically the people not say
there are there doesn't they're not as
resilient and things like that what's
been your experience in well I think I
think for us and when I first started
doing this type of recruitment like I
said before sales was a much less
desired profession to get into so people
it felt to me like people change their
minds a lot more and we're a bit more
flaky whereas now I think because the
jobs that we recruit for are truly the
best in the market if you want to get
into if you want to be an SDR and you
want to wear your SAS and I find the
candidates more committed fair enough I
think obviously they're young people and
it can it can be challenging because
they can you know change their mind or
not really know what they want to do but
then in the same breath it's also really
rewarding because you're genuinely
helping people start their careers yeah
I think that's a really cool thing and
what you've been involved in is I'm sure
there's loads of people that you've
helped I don't know four years ago two
years ago where they're now like sales
manager web so that must be really cool
to see from afar and I feel a bit sorry
for them because I think they get a bad
press with all this kind of snakes and
stuff I think it's just reflective of
the world changing yeah not necessarily
FiOS you can't generalize there will be
people there may be on those resilient
but yeah definitely unfair - yeah okay
that's interesting okay cool so and last
year then so that was so that's last
year was your third or fourth year yeah
fourth year yeah
so how let's break down how you how
you've done them because you've had to
build up this mod from scratch it seems
like being a super proactive recognizing
opportunity early on and then since then
you just been absolutely hammering it
building relationships getting more
credibility having more success yeah so
like how did you do last year personally
in terms of billing yes so I did 560
okay in total and yeah that's all perm
right yeah let's talk about for a second
that's I mean that's really good
[Laughter]
[Music]
for 50 the year before Synnex 100k
pretty much yeah
and then my target this year 600 what
you do in the first year that not 300 at
Bennett Eric
yeah like 'yeah round that really
[ __ ] hell that's mental so this is
the reason why I'm reacting like that so
this is interesting right so I get to
sit down with people like you on this
podcast yeah
now you when like so obviously you get
access and see Billings within your four
walls right you get to see like what so
I've had quite a few message reasons
like Hisham I build this much this year
like I know how that compares to like my
peers but like do you have any idea how
that compares with the market stuff that
so that the reason why I'm reacting like
that is because I think the post not too
long ago on sort of people asking that
question just because I'm in this sort
of unique position I get to sit down
people you and talk about how your
successes stuff like that and I think
it's really interesting it you can only
you only have access to what's within
your four walls and what came out of
this post anywhere in the comment
section stuff like that I'm not a
rhetoric so but a lot of people said
there if you're in a pen Billa and
you're doing 200 plus 250 K Plus that
scene is like a really you've done
really well right let's just talk about
that for a second because I think that's
a lot of people you saying that you may
not realize it but a lot of people may
listen tango [ __ ] how she done that
like a lot of people may think that's
not achievable right and I've quoted
quite a few times now but I think it's
so powerful is like again coming back to
like you only have access to what's in
your four walls like you can only be
what you see yeah so people around you
might be doing those numbers and you
like it yeah well this is I'm just
competing I don't to be a bottom of the
pack like this is what I've got to do to
be at the top right so what is it what
do you think that's really enabled you
to just continue building on that
because that's that's really impressive
so like how have you continued to
increase that so I think I think number
one our model really lends itself to be
able being able to build a lot of money
because it's high volume because it's
high volume and because we run an
assessment center every single week
and because of where we are as a
business now and we've got so many
clients that want access to our
candidates yeah each week we've got the
opportunity to probably place about 20
jobs yes not bad yes so I think the
model definitely really helps and we
also sponsor an event called sales
confidence yes which you may oh yeah and
that's really helped us establish our
brand in the marketplace and also
generate lots of clients so I think
that's definitely helped but then from a
personal standpoint I think it goes back
to that high volume of activity thing
and I think you know making sure you
having lots of conversations on a day to
day basis well what's the I feel like
you you know what it's like a good
number to aim for used a what just break
that down a bit some more granular
details light foods look back on your
day what would what would make you feel
like you know I've had a really cracking
day today like how many conversations
and stuff um Intel on a daily basis so
again it's different now than what it
used to be because now as well we get
lots of inbound leads so it's not as
much of a cold yeah but I think we used
to target on something like 50
decision-makers a week yeah
so trying to trying to come speak to
yeah 10 decision-makers a day yeah nice
and then that could be like 50 calls to
get - did you make it speech you having
10 conversations a day with
decision-makers you're gonna give
yourself best horse of chance
making money there aren't you ok just to
add a bit more to that point I think
also a big thing at Bennett Rix and
definitely some burger lanes taught me
is to never cut corners so we have a
process that feels quite rigid to
candidates and clients sometimes but it
really works and we get everybody to buy
into us and then stick to our process
and that gets the best results for the
candidates the clients and then also for
Bellatrix nice so that process is I'm
sure enable you to qualify people out
exactly yeah so that means that what
you've got really slicker is working and
building relationships with people that
value what you do and they bought into
the process which means that more chance
are you gonna make place
exactly yes okay
how have you I'll just look in the
question here like I feel like obviously
we've what you do every Wednesday grads
and like it would it be I might be
making the wrong assumption here but a
lot of people may if you're in that sort
of environment like could make that
quite transactional or just keep
transactional so how have you gone about
ensuring that is in a transactional
relationship the people that you're
working with with their candidate yeah
connects or clients well with their
candidates we train them once we place
them so we get the opportunity to see
them throughout their first year yeah
and check in with them go for drinks
with them offer them additional support
and we also see lots of our candidates
and clients at the sales confidence
event that I mentioned so that gives us
the opportunity to have loads of face
time with them and a lot of a lot of my
clients for example don't really feel
like clients because we like whatsapp
each other all the time
sends like funny gifts or whatever so on
I'm not just speaking to so for the
recruiter when I need 10 grads - it's
more than that right yeah exactly yeah
ok so I think you mentioned this to me
out the sales confidence event actually
when we just spoke briefly and
introduced to you but you mentioned now
around inbound leads yeah so I'm sure a
lot of that's what referrals yeah yeah
and obviously you guys do quite a bit on
LinkedIn yeah how impactful is a thin
and I think that's completely changed
our business really yeah a hundred
percent because I think that it gives
you that human element where people
don't just think you're a recruitment
company and like we've got a lady called
Terry Jackson that works at Bennett
Rick's and she is only about two years
into our recruitment career but when we
go to events people go up to her and
they're like oh my god are you that girl
from LinkedIn because she does so much
video content so many pictures yeah and
and I think Matt's really helped because
it number one it gets your content out
there because people view it share it
like it and but then it also enables
people look
from the outside to get to know you and
realize that we're just people and that
sounds really simple but obviously it's
what I do now but like 90% of recruiters
they don't look human online is mental I
think what we do as well has a very
human element to it because it's placing
graduates into their first job in sales
companies which you know is quite like
an emotional decision for the company
and for the client I think that helps us
as well yeah that's interesting and then
what about your own personal journey
that have you ever you have you found it
putting loads of contact I didn't
actually look at if that's something
that you do quite a lot is that
something you do personally quite a lot
as well yeah I don't do it as much as
the team that generate the candidates
but yeah it's definitely something that
you know if we're trying to push a
specific job or if I'm tryna yeah and
get more clients on board doing
something like a video you do feel quite
exposed I think more people are doing it
now so don't know if it's having as much
impact does it did you know maybe a year
or so ago it's definitely I mean for me
it's definitely not like for me it's
that plus trying to have 10 the
conversation a decision-makers a day you
know I mean it's definitely yeah it's
got about combining the boniface yeah
but the great thing about that is if you
are a bit more visible online then you
get free set decision maker there might
be more of a chance that I actually yes
I've seen some of your stuff and that
massively helped us right yeah exactly
and we get lots of inbound leads from
companies that say they've seen various
videos that the guys have done on
LinkedIn yeah and they kind of get to
know the personality of the company and
then they think oh we'd actually like to
hire candidates that are similar to
those people yeah sure that really helps
so someone I was just interested
thinking about Antony was so obviously
as we know you've been your complete
focus on clients so like how how have
you been I'm assuming then some of your
colleagues just focus on kind of a it's
like delivery right so so does that fair
this bit of like a 180 model pretty much
and yeah so as people progress through
Venna tricks they get given a
relationships to look after
okay and then they start to learn how to
do business development but it's um yeah
it's mainly as a 180 model yeah nice
what have you found what it's like so
i've sat down with a lot of people there
and doing that really well or thinking
about it or really transition to it on
yeah so like how have what are some of
those sort of learnings there on
ensuring that that's really successful
so I guess what I'm trying to get out is
you just deliver on crying slight it's
going to be really important that your
guys deliver right so like how important
is the communication internally if
you're just dealing with the clients and
then they're doing the candidates for
your clients which that's your
reputation as their reputation how yeah
how have you found like how does that
work and how yeah well there's only ten
of us and we are in a we work office
which everyone knows on the biggest yeah
so we're pretty much around each other
all day every day and we do I'd say we
have really good communication so we do
whenever we get a new job on will
whoever got the job well like pitch it
to the team get everybody really excited
about it and we have lots of
conversations where we go through every
single job that we've got and every
single candidate that we've got and make
sure that we haven't missed any matches
where we could be arranging interviews
and do you have like a conversation I
recently like it getting back to you you
said you have a really strict process
they have a they have that model as well
and they have like a really like strict
process on like if you take on a job and
I sit down with the delivery person like
I've got go I've got to have all the
correct information like so there's a
really strict process in between you
telling me about a job and me finding
out about your job yeah exactly is that
pretty slick yeah it's really slick yes
that's important right yeah okay cool so
couple awesome before we finish yeah I'd
love to get your foot because obviously
now like there's ten of you and I'm sure
as you said you just send their that how
people come progress and they can get to
do more business velopment stuff like
that from your perspective now fair to
say that you're pretty seasoned business
development person and like what are
some of those sort of I know we've
spoken a bit about the Malheur on but
sort of to round it all off really like
what are some of the sort of common
things you see in the people around you
I have seen that you think prevent them
from
doing really well at business you picked
up on so I think it's really easy to
feel like when something goes wrong it's
the end of the world yes and so I spend
a lot of time saying to the team or
Elaine has said it to me many times as
well like just remember this is only a
job and if that client doesn't want to
meet you it doesn't matter it's not life
or death so I think being able to like
really lift yourself out of the
situation and not let the hard times get
you down is a big one I think another
thing going back to the whole process
thing when things don't work out when we
break down have they followed the
process enough where they engage with
the decision maker did they ask all the
right questions on the call you'll often
find when it does go wrong something to
be missed so I think making sure that
people and stick to the formula that
works for their business and image even
results like that so that leads me quite
nicely into what our answers will get
your thoughts on was and so what's your
first point now around what you're
talking about there is sort of mindset
perspective and getting better at
understanding that okay that was just a
no it's not the end of the world like
what how lie is it fair to say they
obviously how what's your jelly bean
with sort of mindset really because
recruitments difficult right yeah
especially in doing what you do and just
obviously and building relationships
doing a lot of that sometimes for the
first time like how have you become
better at managing your own sort of
stress and mentality and ensuring you're
always sort of a top performance so I
think in the first few years it didn't
really affect me because it was very
much a new experience very exciting and
kind of maybe I felt like I was on a bit
of a roll with it but definitely when we
started Venna tricks and I felt a lot of
responsibility to generate all these
clients yeah to keep the business kind
of ticking along it I definitely let it
get to me and had lots of moments where
I felt really stressed sometimes felt
like it was too much and maybe you know
I didn't know if I could do it
thing but I think you like the more
difficult times you go to the more
easier is to kind of brush them off
because you've been through that
situation before and and I think just
remembering sorry to repeat myself but
it is just a job and no one's gonna die
like I get that I think that's so
completely that is a great way to think
about it sometimes this light right I
care about a [ __ ] day today but light
yeah as you said all the people I care
about still alive like right you know I
mean and you can think that is a good
place to go sometimes when yeah you feel
like I'm not sure I could do this
anymore like yeah obviously if you're
consistently not hitting your target
then maybe unique is it the right job
for you if you have a bad day a bad week
up month I'm sure there's a lot worse
things going on in the world that you
can be worrying about than that yeah cuz
I always and then also just just to sort
of touch on that is that sort of some of
the things you said it's one of the
questions that I'm looking at is sort of
yeah mental health stress the
recruitment managing especially like
from your perspective now you're quite
experienced as you said you've probably
had quite a few moments where like this
is tough but now you can you know you've
got through them yeah
whereas people quite early on a more
junior they haven't got that to lean on
do you not I mean yes why are you
talking to people about not being in
your shoes it's gonna be okay and sort
of have those sorts of conversations at
people yeah have a phrase at Bennett Rix
that one of my colleagues George always
says we go again so that happens we just
don't we go again cool so and we're not
ask you a couple of questions on
resilience yeah and because of the event
and I have coming up but before I do and
how of so you been in recruitment
now I mean you're going toward a decade
right how how do you see recruitment
changing from your perspective like what
what do you find how do you think
recruitment is changing or how do you
think recruitment is going to look in
the next couple years out of interest so
I think a great thing about working in
recruitment is that companies are always
gonna need to hire good people
and I think a lot of people say like are
you worried that the robots are gonna
take over I'm gonna need recruiters
anymore but I think it is a very human
form of sales for sure and because it's
a service-based industry I think that
people are always going to want those
person-to-person interactions mmm so I
think it will just get bigger and better
to be honest I think sir okay cool so
kind of questions and resilience and
then we'll finish so Sophie what what
does resilience and recruitment mean to
you not worrying about the outcome mmm I
like that how how has the importance or
needs for resilience changed as the
industry's evolved what you mean so how
how has one the importance of resilience
mm or need for resilience yeah changed
as the industry's changed it's quite
different now right from maybe when you
started so I guess what I'm trying to
just ask you is and how has resilience
changes or the need for resilience
changed or has the type of resilience
changed as things have changed I don't
think so to be honest okay I think
you're always gonna need resilience in
any type of sales role and maybe it's
different types of resilience as
industries change but I think in yeah I
don't think it has changed that much
okay and what what can people do
themselves to instill instill resilience
in them or their teams and so I think I
think it's really important like I said
to remember that it's just a job not be
too worried about the outcome all of the
time and then I think you're more
resilient in work when you look after
yourself outside of work as well because
it puts you in a better mental state for
the day and then when bad things happen
they don't hit you as hard so not sound
like a cliche but things like getting
lots of sleep going to the gym
and having a healthy lifestyle outside
of work really helped me with my like
mental state and my attitude when I'm in
work nice awesome love that so before I
ask you the final question what what is
Sophie excited about in 2020 and beyond
what's your show about what you excited
about so I'm really excited about our
partnership with sales confidence and
because like I said that's helped us
generate a lot of clients and we sponsor
the event now so we and get to go to all
of the events have our name out there we
get shout outs yeah you definitely show
clients from the guy that runs it yeah
so that's always really exciting I'm
really excited about Venna tricks
establishing its senior division so that
we can capitalize even more on our
relationships are you going to be
actively involved in that and yeah
definitely and we are hiring for people
with recruitment experience at the
moment to drop that in there that's cool
so yeah definitely really excited about
that and then I think again excited
about the unknown because it's a startup
and because things happen and we can
take on pretty much any challenge I'm
excited for the things that we don't
haven't planned for that are gonna
happen this year yeah I think yeah I
think you've been on awesome journey so
far it's good excited to see how it all
evolves and to look final question and
you can answer this question with a
phrase a word sentence whatever comes to
mind
but if Sophie could communicate to every
single recruits are out there they'd
listen they take on an advice that
implements it tomorrow what do you say
to the people it's a tough job that's
somebody's got to do it servants been a
pleasure thank you thank you very much